[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday July 12
I'm in a pizza restaurant pretty much
completely alone except for Catherine
who's here because she just come back
from her work trip and I'm really glad
to see her and I would like to be
spending all of my time with her but I
can't because I have to make a video so
instead I'm making a video while I'm
spending time with her at a pizza
restaurant this is definitely the
delicious dist peeps a restaurant in
Missoula delicious issed make pretty
good money here the good news is that
were the only people here because it's
like 2:30 not really time for lunch
except for the cooks and waitstaff but
they kind of all work for me because I'm
paying with an ATM stuff so they're not
allowed to be discouraged by my
videotaping
I still don't know what you want me to
do for my punishment exactly so I'm not
gonna do it today but you need to clear
that up on Friday so that I can be sure
that I'm doing the right thing and then
I'm not still punished after I finish my
punishment I like the green hair idea
with spray paint but I don't think that
that's a suitably punishment because
especially it just washes out after a
day so yeah it looks good challenge it's
a good fun time thing to do but not
necessarily a punishment Wow I sure
can't argue with Walmart nerdfighters
this is how much pizza is left that is
Katherine here so I can't eat it I would
like to eat it but we split it in half
and that is not my piece not so guess
what Katherine and I are about to go do
we're going to see Harry Potter at the
five o'clock matinee showing because
that is the only time we go to see
movies anymore now even in Missoula a
movie costs eight dollars and fifty
cents never ever go without a soda in
your pocket because the sodas are like
seven dollars for the little one getting
very excited about all this Harry Potter
madness having a hard time holding in my
excitement for the book which I think
comes out in well stays 13 days it's
very soon I hope that I'll have to do a
video on that day because I won't be
able to because I will be reading Harry
Potter but I just wanted to say that I
think that a good challenge is just to
wear our nerdfighter shirts in public
because people always look at me funny
and then sometimes they ask me what
other times they just look at me and
they kind of ask me with their eyes plus
then you get to like explain Brotherhood
2.0 to them maybe we should have
business cards as for your punishment
people seem to be really excited about
you doing that half-naked dance with a
golden bowtie well really I mean it's
gonna be black and white so anything
that looks like it could be a golden
bowtie just put that on and then you do
that naked dance for you know 10 15
seconds maybe a little bit more than
that how about 30 seconds you don't have
to show all of that so you can just pick
the best part but I want to see some
good half-naked dancing I think that's
what I want to see you do for your
punishment me whatever you want man okay
I'm almost home so John I will see you
tomorrow